>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
THE RAPIDLY DETERIORATING
SITUATION, VIOLENCE AND CHAOS
BREAKING OUT ALL OVER IN THE
NATION OF SOUTH AFRICA, FOX'S
TRACE GALLAGHER HAS THE VERY
LATEST OF THE SAD SORRY FOR US
RIGHT NOW.
>> TUCKER, IT'S IMPOSSIBLE NOT
TO DRAW PARALLELS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN SOUTH AFRICA AND
WHAT HAPPENED HERE IN THE U.S.
AFTER THE DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD
AND WHAT COULD EASILY HAPPEN
AGAIN IN THIS COUNTRY WHEN
POLICE ARE OUTNUMBERED AND
OVERWHELMED.
THIS VIDEO IS FROM THE PROBLEMS
WHERE A MALL IS ENGULFED IN
FLAMES AND RIOTERS ARE
DOMINATING THE POLICE PRESENCE
THERE.
YOU CAN ALSO SEE LOOTERS GOING
DOWN THE ROAD WITH BOXES FILLED
WITH GOODS PILED UP ON TRUCKS,
DOLLIES, CARTS, EVEN A TRACTOR.
POLICE ARE FIRING WHAT APPEAR TO
BE RUBBER BULLETS AT THE LARGER
GROUPS AND GET THIS, WITNESSES
SAY EVEN ARMED SOUTH AFRICAN
CITIZENS WERE FIRING ON PEOPLE
IN THE STREET, THOUGH IT'S
UNCLEAR HOW MANY, IF ANY OF
THEM, WERE HIT.
AND WATCH AND LISTEN TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
>> AND REMEMBER THE CONTEXT
HERE.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE A PROTEST
ABOUT SOUTH AFRICA'S FORMER
PRESIDENT BEING IMPRISONED FOR
CONTEMPT OF COURT AND GET THE
CROWDS OF PEOPLE ARE USING IT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO STEAL
EVERYTHING FROM FURNITURE TO
ELECTRICAL APPLIANCES AND NOW
LOOK AT SOUTH AFRICA'S MOST
POPULAR -- POPULACE PROVINCE,
WHERE THERE IS ESTABLISH FOOTAGE
OF RIOTERS AND LOOTERS RUNNING
INSIDE OF SHOPPING CENTER
CARRYING BAGS AND OTHER ITEMS
AND AGAIN PEOPLE ARE POINTING
WEAPONS AT THE LOOTERS, BUT IT'S
A TOTAL MISMATCH.
AND JUST LIKE WE SAW IN AMERICA,
SOUTH AFRICA'S SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND THE POOR ARE BEARING
THE BRUNT OF THIS BECAUSE THEIR
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN DESTROYED
AND CRITICAL PUBLIC SERVICES
LIKE ELECTRICITY AND WATER HAVE
BEEN DISRUPTED.
SO FAR WE HAVE CONFIRMED TEN
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KILLED IN THE
CHAOS.
THAT NUMBER WILL ALMOST
CERTAINLY RISE.
TALKER.
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANKS SO MUCH.
MUCH MORE ON WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
SOUTH AFRICA TOMORROW AND
POSSIBLY THE DAY AFTER, ASSUMING
IT CONTINUES.
THE LINKS BETWEEN THIS COUNTRY
AND SOUTH AFRICA ARE DEEP AND
PROFOUND, PARTICULARLY
POLITICALLY, OUR RULING CLASS
DID A LOT TO EMPOWER THE CURRENT
GOVERNMENT OF SOUTH AFRICA AND
THERE MAY BE LESSONS FOR THE
WORLD AND WHAT'S HAPPENI